bumping around the sky holding onto our
seats Duke and Duchess of Cambridge were
on board this plane the lightning
outside the window as the pilots tried
to land in islamabad this was the plane
we were flying on the RAF Voyager seen
earlier in the day as William and Kate
arrived in Lahore
Prince William told us they were fine
after turbulence after checking the rest
of press pack were okay too
it came after a heartwarming day of
engagements wah theorem Ani who's only
seven had them 14 she has kidney cancer
but is getting the best possible
treatment at this hospital partly thanks
to money that Princess Diana helped to
raise through her visits here in the
mid-90s her legacy is important than
both but they also have their own
interests Kate wanted to visit this
orphanage called the SOS village we were
invited inside one of the houses
in Pakistan four and a half million
children have either lost their parents
or been abandoned celebrating their work
in her only speak to this talk was
important the Kate William I have seen
on several occasions how family is at
the heart of your culture that is not
simply the term that describes the
relationship between mud predators
instead it describes those special bonds
we share with all those who make us feel
safe and supported it isn't always easy
for her to get her message across when
so much attention often goes on what she
wears like other women who have married
into this life these tours help the
likes of the Duchess of Cambridge really
define what her role is but it is a
careful balancing act between her
personality the causes that she cares
about and what the world expects of her
as a member of the royal family they've
been getting lots of coverage for this
war even before their flight drama they
know it's all about putting on a good
performance
Rihanna Mills Sky News in Pakistan